kathy wood yaseen and arkhan vest
they're going all in on bitcoin well
kind of ultimately there's a new report
out from our that shows how bitcoin can
get to one million dollars by 2030.
let's dig into it yaseen started out
with this great tweet he said the price
of a single bitcoin could exceed 1
million dollars by 2030. we are still
early now if we go ahead and we zoom in
on this exact image that they're talking
about here what they are showing is the
bitcoin market capitalization ends up
being by the end of 2030
28.5
billion i'm sorry trillion dollars 28.5
trillion dollars today that would be
almost 28 x from where it is at the
moment and of course if you go ahead and
you start to break down what exactly
adds up to that 28.5 trillion dollars
they think the remittance network the
emerging market currency the economic
settlement layer the nation state
treasury the seizure resistant asset the
institutional investment the corporate
treasury end the digital gold you add
all of that up they think that it can
get to 28.5 trillion dollars that would
be the equivalent of 1.36 million
dollars per bitcoin now if you go ahead
and you look at the global asset values
you can see that bitcoin has significant
appreciation potential ultimately
bitcoin is very very small it is only
1.1 trillion or so gold's 10 trillion
global equities 106 trillion global m2
supply 123 trillion global bonds 124
trillion and global real estate sits at
220 trillion dollars so bitcoin going
from 1.1 to 28.5 it's a 25.9 x that
would only be
about double a little bit more than
double gold it wouldn't even get you
anywhere near global equities
if we then go ahead and look at
bitcoin's market participants and as
they are maturing and focusing on the
long term you can see that bitcoin's
aggregate cost basis hit a new record
high in 2021. bitcoin's market
capitalization grew by 96 percent in
2021 and its realized cap grew by 168
percent also the long-term holder base
hit an all-time high in 2021 as well
those long-term holders hold about 13.5
million bitcoin with more than 500 000
addresses exhibiting long-term holding
behavior and then if we go ahead and we
look and the actual market share where
is it stealing market share from well
that cumulative transfer value increased
by 463 percent in 2021 bitcoin's annual
settlement volume surpassed visas
payment volume that is very important to
understand here my friends is that
bitcoin's annual settlement volume has
surpassed visas payment volumes when you
start to look at that you can start to
understand that regardless of what you
hear in the mainstream media regardless
of what your friend your mom your cousin
or your neighbor told you bitcoin is
used by lots of people around the world
it's used on an actual transaction
settlement bases
more than visa is which is an important
piece to understand and then ultimately
could bitcoin continue to scale and
respond to technological breakthroughs
kathy wood you've seen an arc they
believe that it absolutely can there's
the successful soft fork activation
there's the layer two growth and bitcoin
denominated defy all things that
continue to lead to more and more
adoption which also increases the
scalability as these technologies come
to fruition and then if we go ahead and
we look at the institutional holders
ladies and gentlemen they come in and
they're coming fast and furious that
institutional holder base appears to be
broadening after the launch of more
regulated products and adoption by
corporations and nation states you can
see that grayscale's bitcoin trust holds
about 654 000 bitcoin you can see block
one and microstrategy both hold between
120 140 000 bitcoin you can see the coin
shares xbt provider they've got about 48
000 bitcoin all the way down to galaxy
digital in their etp they have 16 400
bitcoin ultimately what we are watching
is institutions across the market
whether they're large financial
institutions whether they're publicly
traded companies or they are providing
some sort of product to their customers
they continue to adopt bitcoin in a very
real way on top of that lastly el
salvador is the first nation state on
top of the institutional adoption the
first nation state to adopt bitcoin as
legal tender in el salvador more people
have bitcoin wallets than traditional
bank accounts it's very important to
understand 1.9 million people have a
traditional bank account but 3.8 now
over 4 million it's reported uh have the
chivo wallet which is that bitcoin
wallet so ultimately what we are
watching is we are watching the adoption
of bitcoin across many different
verticals from individuals to
organizations to nations things and this
is just the start of something that
likely will be a decades-long trend if
that decades-long trend plays out
arc believes kathy believes and yassine
believes that it could reach as high as
28.5
trillion dollar market cap to be a 1.3
million bitcoin price by 2030. a lot of
people who say a lot of crazy numbers
but they got the data the analysis and
the scrutiny to back up their thought
process maybe they're right maybe
they're not but it seems to be a pretty
rational view of the world in my opinion